hi I'm John duet with the North Dakota
State University extension service I'm
an area livestock specialist and I'm
pleased to welcome you to our program on
background and Cavs in
2015 each fall our Ranchers have to make
some production and marketing plans and
typically about half of them we their
Cales and feed them for a period of time
to heavier weights which we call
backgrounding the fundamentals factors
which go into the profitability of this
uh Enterprise vary quite a bit from year
to year we've had recent years of
extremely high grain prices we've had
years of rising rapidly Rising cattle
prices during this backgrounding phase
but today 2015 we're faced with fairly
cheap abundant feed and a cattle market
which has been on the downslide so I
think to get things started here and
getting a little insight into the
economics and what the potential is for
backgrounding this year I'm going to ask
a few questions of our livestock
marketing Economist Tim Petri who's
stationed at the NDSU campus in Fargo so
Tim I guess you know this Market's
really been moving a lot mostly down
what are your price expectations for the
550 lb kind of vaccinated calf coming
off the cow going into the market today
yeah sure I agree that we really have
had a volatile Market with last year
record high increases and then the last
couple of months we've had a big
downtrend uh Main causes for the decline
being a contra seasonal downward fed
cattle market caused by many factors
including a backlog of heavy cattle and
record weights also record high pork
production you're going to hear record a
lot today record high pork and poultry
production and a stagnant export market
so uh yeah price expectations is a very
good question uh somewhat difficult to
answer probably due to the wide ranging
prices for the same weight and greater C
at the same Market uh again due to many
factors such as are they weaned or
unweaned uh or preconditioned do they
have health programs and so on so uh I
expect another 20 to $30 range like kind
of happened last year and in prices at
the same Caves at the same market and so
uh as we can see in the chart we have a
more normal seasonal pattern this year
with declining prices in the second half
compared to last year when they went up
every year so keep that in mind um we
are expecting calf prices to be about 25
to 30 Cent per lower than last year so
for example a 550 steer last year that
brought 280 is closer to $200 even to
210 this year of course every Market has
good news and bad news for those selling
caves the bad news is we're below last
year and probably below earlier
expectations of a few months ago but the
good news is we still have the second
highest price prices ever but for those
buying Cales it's still going to mean
that they're going to have to come up
with a lot of money I think we'll sell a
lot of steer Cavs in that 195 to 210
area and again like always heers are
really discounted this time of the year
$20 or for the lower end even more so uh
that puts them in about 175 to
190 sometimes we see some preferences
for the real light C especially when we
have a good winter wheat crop down south
and they need some great in animals I
would think with the price of wheat this
year not looking too optimistic there'd
be some interest in grazing what do we
see on the slide on the weight classes
between lights and Heavies okay yeah
well we really haven't had a good test
to light caves yet because we have such
good conditions out in North Dakota and
there hasn't been much weaning or light
caves brought to Market uh but for sure
the price slide is a lot less than it
has been the last couple of years there
are several reasons for that um most of
the calves coming to market now are not
weaned or preconditioned and our balling
calves that's typical of an early Market
again not many being sold you mentioned
winter wheat and that is the big one uh
winter wheat planting is way behind
schedule particularly in Texas and
Oklahoma and it's dry down there and so
that market has not materialized yet
with the weather pattern where we they
are expecting rain and we hope that we
get it but so far that is not
materialized and and so uh the market is
really encouraging producers to wean and
precondition Cales looking at the charts
for instance for last week uh average
550 steers were about 205 but the 750 to
eights were only $10 behind at 195 so uh
last year the market was $40 differ so
we need that winter wheat crop to really
materialize to to get any spark in those
lighter calves well you you've given us
a pretty good indication where she's
trading in this early market and also
said they were're kind of seasonally
normal starting to slide down as the the
runs of Cavs come to town can we expect
some uh when we could hit a seasonal low
and when can we expect some recovery or
is this all guessing game well that's a
good question and yeah Cals do usually
reach a seasonal low in November when
all the cattle come off of pastures and
the big runs hit the market as the chart
shows the market is already declined
since August about 20 to 25% so the big
seasonal decline is behind us in fact
it's one of the largest in history
declines here in the last couple months
so um some weakness still may occur
especially in those unweaned calves
without a health program or uh you know
that are the less optimistic calves
there but uh uh and you know there's a
lot of volatility and certainty in the
market which causes buyers to be a
little bit more reluctant on those uh
calves that don't have a health program
and so on but if we can get some rain in
the winter wheat belt and get some
seasonal strength back in the feeder in
the FED cattle market that is which is
possible that would support prices uh
however we're not going to go back to
last year's prices for sure and
cyclically we are on the downtrend so we
need to keep that in mind well we know
backgrounding works really well when
you're in a rising market because then
the price cattle get more valuable every
day you got them and you feed them and
take care of them uh big question now is
what are these six s 800 pound feeders
going to be worth come January February
March because if we had a good idea on
that then we'd kind of know how this is
going to pan out yeah that's always the
$64 question and while calf prices tend
to increase after the first of the year
the heavier weights often do decline
after the first of the year would be a
normal seasonal pattern however the
range in prices for those heavier weight
cattle do narrow because they have been
weaned they have had a health program
and so on uh January to March feeder
cattle futures are trading below cash
prices now in fact just a couple of
weeks ago they were a lot lower they've
rebounded $10 to2 so we've got January
Futures in at about 180 now and the
March Futures in a little dollar or so
lower than that um still below the CME
cash settlement price which is all 650
to 850 Cavs so the Futures is still
discounted to the current cash market so
I think uh as a first step we do have to
look at the Futures Market as a Target
uh hopefully we can get some strength as
I mentioned before back in that fed
cattle market and we can do better than
that but also keep in mind that there's
always risk in a volatile market so
producers need to ke keep that in mind
as
well well we got a little idea where the
cattle are trading where they might be
going using the Futures a bit of a guide
feed is fairly cheap interest is kind of
low fuel cost is down quite a bit what
would be your cost of gain Target for
Cavs doing that two to two and a half a
day in a backgrounding program yeah okay
feed prices do vary quite a bit across
the state and we do have a wide variety
of feed stuffs and speakers later are
going to discuss some of those uh it
even depends on if you're selling corn
to the elevator versus buying corn there
might be a 30 Cent difference there so
that obviously affects our uh bottom
line but you know I think now we should
look at the low 50s for a cost of gain
some certainly with lower feed costs and
lot costs and so on will do it in the
40s a few might even be up in the 60s
but let's shoot for those lower $50
range is a good starting point well that
is kind of with those kind of cost of
gain projections and uh kind of our uh
slide on the weight classes narrowing up
this year when you put it all together
what's the budget show there a little
room here to make some money background
and gavs yeah absolutely on my website I
have an Excel spreadsheet that producers
can use plugin their own information
there's also a calf web break even
budget there so in the example you see
on the screen now I just brought in a
550 weight calf at $25 and then a 750
calf out at
$175 and January March whatever you want
to use I have a 2 and 3/4 pound of gain
uh corn at $3 again corn is kind of all
over the board my example shows about a
$50 per head return and interestingly
enough I went back to last year at this
time when calf prices were a lot higher
280 Cavs we're projecting 230 out came
out to $50 last year at this time so the
market does try to I think encourage
some backgrounding and and some return
there and very similar to last year but
you know it looks like we can background
calves as we all know however there are
many factors that affect calf prices and
there is risk and we've seen that in the
last couple years but that's how it
looks right now well thank you Tim for
sharing those uh insights into the
economics maybe backgrounding this year
is there anything else you want to pass
along as we close well uh you know uh
again going back to that wide range in
calf prices uh if you look at the bottom
level and and add value to some calves
that helps heers are always discounted
this time of the year and uh sometimes
are really a nice Market class to
background because every 50 pounds we
gain prices on steer Cav so uh you know
just uh look for some of the best
opportunities there for making some
money thanks